you know you know as as a young as a
good irish guy you know i love drinking
you know it was it was part of my
everyday thing and it was always there
and accessible especially in hollywood
it's like hey nail have a drink have
another drink have another drink yeah
and five years ago i just cut it out i
said okay i'm done i can't do this
anymore and for five years i've been
sober and it's been
you know you know
the greatest decision second greatest
decision i ever made in my life other
than obviously asking river to marry me
were you were you drinking a lot though
for someone yeah i was you know i was a
hollywood guy you're always drinking
there's no it's always part and i'm
irish so you know it definitely became a
problem for me and it was a problem that
i didn't want my kids to see and i
didn't want
look being being trying to be the best
dad you can be
that doesn't fit in trying to be the
best husband you can be it doesn't fit
in and trying to be great at work
you know the last five years have worked
for me have been you know really just
phenomenal from just being
you know the bad guy in everything to
you know the good guy now i'm off doing
ryan murphy just called me this week to
to play eisenhower in american horror
story wow
wow i could totally see that oh i can
totally see that's fantastic yeah so you
know you know the good lord works in
strange ways here we are you know are
moving back to california don't know
where don't know what we're going to do
and then we get this they're you know
shooting the show now this fall you know
at fox
you know it's it's a great way to come
back into los angeles uh and i you know
i couldn't be happier or more blessed
that that this gift was given to me from
above and from ryan murphy that's
amazing
uh when i meet ryan there's gonna be a
big hug going his way because that's
that's such a great gift to play
someone that i have always looked up to
as you know
you know a centrist when it comes to
politics as was eisenhower
you know the things that that guy did
you know everyone you know he was he
almost ran out of the democratic tech he
almost ran the republican you know he
finally ran a public integrity ticket
but now he he was this amazing guy who
cared so much about humanity and
uh learning so much about him now in the
last couple of days doing more research
i'm just i'm i'm
you know
gobsmacked at how fortunate i am to play
something amazing like